thank you I trying to work with a shower
on or you'll know fan Benny Pincus and
thanks especially thanks to Mike for
giving all the background necessaries
now you just go straight into what we're
doing score cut exactly so as Mike
mentioned yow proved a fundamental
feasibility theorem as a feasibility
theorem but ever since then there's been
a long series of very significant
optimizations that have resulted in
amazing speed so aes circuit which is
just an example of about seven thousand
and gates a bit less we can now garble
in about three hundred microseconds on a
regular machine nothing very special
about it so this is amazing progress and
it's the balance a result of all of this
this long series of improvements might
even go into so much explicitly mention
about that big slide with the times is
all about different double encryption
methods using a hash using a c-56 using
AES ni however all of this all of these
optimizations come at some price in
terms of assumptions now based on
yesterdays assumptions so I'm talking
about more sort of 90s sort of stuff so
so freaks or can be proven secure under
a random Oracle assumption or under some
type of circular security but it's not
just circular security there's also a
related key or a correlation robust if
using like hash functions the
correlation robustus but talking about a
yes then it's really a related key
assumption so you need circularity and
related key assumption flexor which mike
mentioned gets rid of circularity since
some one type of flexor but it does
still need a related key in general if
you want to do a single encryption pro
cipher text instead of two encryptions /
cipher text you need a related he
assumption this thing about these
aes-256 mint mint idea that mike
mentions we take two 128-bit keys and we
can catenate them to get a 256-bit key
we're now we're doing we have four
cipher texts and in each ciphertext two
of the keys there are two keys that are
repeated so we have a key we have keys
appearing in different encryptions in
different places so this is exactly a
related key assumption fixed kaes
our requires us to assume that a es is
an ideal cipher and then we have this
graph which says well okay so it'd be
really nice to rely only on surrender
functions but if I really want to be
efficient that I need then then and I go
for an ideal size and look at this
massive massive difference and this is
the picture that pretty much is
correlated to to what Mike showed it's
obviously not exact it's just this was
the easiest line that I could get in out
of power point but it's actually no not
that not that far from how we what our
perception is and this talk actually
thought about maybe trying to change
that perception our perception is
definitely this graph so computer
science do you have such a graph the
paper is accepted ok shall we shorten on
when i submitted so the I wonder what
about AES is an ideal cipher so let's
ask the experts on block ciphers John
black already many over 10 years ago
said that many block cipher people are
comfortable with assuming that a ESS
pseudo-random permutation but not not as
an ideal cipher more recently at
experian curve and others who have
related key attacks on aes say that you
should you cannot model a is 256 at
least as an ideal cipher and this is due
and not to the circularity because i was
talking with that but exactly doing to
the related key attacks so is an ideal
cipher definitely not but even the
related key assumption on areas is
somewhat questionable so why do we
accept these assumptions 1 answer could
be causing cryptos crypto of 2015 all
assumptions are we're happy to live with
them we really don't care anything about
assumptions the other I'm just sort of
you know the other the other possibility
said ok we don't have a choice all right
if we want to make secure pretation
relevant and gobble circles relevant
then our then without these assumptions
it's not going to be fit enough because
we have that graph and if you think of
the slide that the Mike showed if you
want to go back to assuming a PRF then
we're going to garba lat six seconds
instead of at three hundred microseconds
so we do it because we don't have a
choice
and this talk is about asking whether we
really don't have a choice or they were
just stuck in a certain perception about
things that are historical and certain
comparisons that were made that were
historically correct at the time but
maybe today we can do things differently
and maybe we can try and work hard to
optimize things understand that
assumptions rather than running at full
speed towards flaky assumptions so so
there is this particular attack on page
56 and that doesn't mean that that
particular packet brig this there's no
attack on just like with
multi-millionaire linear maps there's no
attack on the construction there's
simply attack on the assumption there's
no no yeah I looked actually really
wanted to too bright to 11 to break it
but I couldn't I could hardly understand
the paper so you know I mean it's block
cipher stuff but yeah I know I tried to
look at it I don't think you can do
anything with it in particular was
interested it can I build a garbled
circuit because i have full full control
over choosing the keys in a way that i
can something weird can have on the
other side when someone evaluates it but
anyway so fixed aes fix key a with a ESN
is incredibly fast but what's the Cabal
was the comparison made to will compare
it at the time that it was a few years
ago it was introduced and it really
improves by orders of magnitude it
compared to the bests that was done then
what was that so a yes 256 which is any
way more expensive than aes-128 and that
implementation of a list of it is 256
was done without the pipelining that the
aes ni instruction gives you so we're
making comparison to the best that it
was but the best it was wasn't that
great according to what we know now it's
compared to hash function computations
which char 256 of shell 1 is actually
much much lower than a yes as it is
especially when you go to a ESN I and
also the speeds are compared to the
amount of time it takes you to compute
the garbled circuit but we're not
interested in computing garbled circuits
we're interested in running a secure
protection protocol so how does the
amount of time it takes to gobble a
circuit or computer circuit 2 evaluated
circuit how much does that effect on the
overall running
the protocol is it a significant part of
the time or is it a non-significant time
of the part but part of the time that's
the question and also want to say the
comparisons that we made five years ago
and not that relevant anymore because
the playing field has changed so much
the size of garble so because the dif
different we now have very very
efficient oblivious transfer which five
years ago or seven years ago we didn't
we hardly had so things have changed so
fast that we need to redress all of
these assumptions that we have and it's
not just on fixed key is also freaks or
so freaks or gives us free evaluation of
XOR gates which is great but if a s is
so fast using the internal instruction
set then does it really matter that I
get it for free instead of computing a
few cycles does it make a big difference
into the computation time in reality it
also gives me zero communication as your
communication as Mike said this is okay
that's great but again does it what
about when we run a protocol on real
circuits in real settings how much of
differences are really make it's
something that we need to understand and
the answer isn't is that are going to be
yes we can get rid of all of these
things but to try to take a first step
to understand what the costs really are
and what the trade-off really is and
that's what we're doing in this in this
in this work how much do these
optimizations really help and the
argument is the conceptual argument is
let's take a step back and revisit our
acceptance of these assumptions as
researchers that stop pause and rethink
we're running a full full full paste
ahead just to make it faster and faster
and faster which is great but let's also
understand loo look in other directions
as well that's what we're doing here and
this may seem strange to some people but
I actually actually argued it's
especially true because we actually want
to use these things why is that because
what happens if in five years time
someone actually breaks fixed key areas
and we don't have any other alternatives
so even if I come up with something
which is thirty percent slower and maybe
no one's going to actually use it
because it's thirty percent slower at
least I have something ready in the bad
event that something happens and
actually in practice people are much
more conservative than often we are in
in here I think most people here would
be happy with 1500 bit RSA keys today
but the industry went from 1000 to 2000
bit right so that they're in some ways
they're often more conservative than we
are and we should be really just in case
bad things happen and this is the sort
of thing that we're trying to do so and
I have much time so just going to give a
very little bit of background to try and
give a brief glimpse into the sort of
things that we've done and i'll show you
the the final results and we can talk
after about details so aes encryption
using the Intel instruction set has two
commands as a SN kinase and class the
reason why you have a different command
for the last is because the last round
of AES doesn't have mixed columns so
it's has a different different
instruction and it's fully pipelined
which means that at every cycle you can
get an output okay so you can we can
essentially encrypt 7 in the latest
chips you can encrypt seven blocks at
almost the same as a crypt in a single
block and blocks so one block takes
about seventy seven cycles the seven
blocks take 81 cycles so really it's the
amount of the cost of encrypting more
more cipher texts is negligible and if
you look at the half gates construction
that Mike mentions so the cost of
evaluating a gate went up from one
encryption 22 encryptions and the answer
is we'll really don't care it's the same
cost the key schedule though is much
much more expensive it uses a command
called aes keygen assist it's not fully
pipelined and the reason is because
nobody bothered to do it it wasn't worth
investing the time and money on the
hardware by Intel because key schedules
are run once and then you use the same
key all the time but not if you want to
gobble the circuit in the standard way
where I use the key as a key and now I
want to do many many key schedules but
the hardware doesn't support that and
that's why it's really really expensive
so you know going to fix kaes made a lot
of sense no key scheduled all the
encryptions are pipelined I don't have
different keys running running around so
it's it's it's really really convenient
and and understanding actually hear how
asni works makes a big difference when
you want to try and do things
efficiently so they
look at these two types of double
encryption both of them encrypt k3 under
two keys k1 and k2 the first cannot be
pipelined in the second can be pipelined
so this will cost double this and that's
exactly the exact the difference between
counter mode and CBC mode if you
actually use CBC mode today it's a
really big mistake it's like more than
five times longer than or is that seven
times longer than using counter mode so
actually to gobble if you want to gobble
under a standard PRF type assumption
just look at aes as a pseudo-random
function nothing more then the and gate
garbling has four keys and we do eight
encryptions and each key is used in to
do in two quick encryptions for
evaluation we have two keys and two
encryptions because we get one of those
cipher text which is encrypted under two
different keys and that cipher text is
doubly encrypted so there are two
encryptions for xor gate garbling we'll
see later on that will actually go into
want for kids or for encryptions but
leave that for later on so we somehow
want to do this very efficiently so you
see the second can be pipeline even use
right so this is actually that this is a
sort of a popular belief that least
amongst people we know yes actually you
don't need to have the same key to
pipeline the instruction gets the key
schedule it gets the round key so if I
prepare two key schedules that I just
take the round here that I want there's
no problem pipeline different case but
it's a very good question
you can get support for that from from
the architecture hey zeg rataxes input
the block and the round key so if i have
enough registers or enough cash i have
to keep things in cash registers
otherwise i'm dead if once i start
reading from memory then everything's
lost if i wanted to do more than four
key four key schedules i want to somehow
keep things in cash i'd lose in the end
there's a balance also between what the
hardware gives you and what the
registers in cash give you so the key
schedule in a is actually consists of NS
s box substitution plus rotates and
shifts which is funny it's sort of very
close to the aes and last operation
except that they're in a SN class there
are other like shifts and stuff and in
the expo and and in a key schedule there
are different types of shifts so if i
really try hard then what I actually do
is I can simulate an alias keep schedule
using various and class operation how do
i do that i use another intel
instruction called PF b which is a
shuffle instruction which also is a
throughput of one to undo the bad stuff
that happened in a ESN classed and read
what i want inside a s key gen assist
and actually get something which is much
much much faster so if you want to do
many many key schedules you can pipeline
the ski trip key schedules you get a
throughput of one because you're using
instructions to give you a throughput of
one a very good pipeline and you can you
have the support to actually do this
very very fast and you can pipeline this
key schedule together with encryptions
as well so if you're doing to
encryptions to teachers to ski key
scheduling to encryptions like when
you're evaluate a circuit you don't have
to call the generator run the key
schedule and then encrypt you can
actually pipeline everything together
and do it much much more efficiently and
these are the type these are this cycle
this is what we get in terms of the
cycles when I say naive implementation
this is not really naive this is the
openssl implementation of the of the kit
of when you call the key schedule open
SSL encryption up in a cell which is
highly optimized using the asn I
infrastructure so its not naive as in
stupid it's naive as in using it the way
it's your expected to use it and just
looking at the the second leg has
foreign four key schedules and aid
encryptions we go down from 729 cycles
to 256 cycles with some additional a
assembler optimizations down to two
hundred forty eight cycles so it's
almost a third of the cost native
instruction thank you excite yeah I knew
that not you so the shy girl run who
worked with on this actually had this
idea but couldn't find anyone who is
interested in in doing many key
schedules and then we started work on
something else and that this is exactly
taking knowledge from different places
and is something that we really needed
and he actually had to do it and then he
had to further optimize based on these
different types of configurations that
we that we wanted it's very optimized
for the specific case you're doing here
because in this for example in this role
you pipeline the encryption and the key
schedule here you don't because you run
out of registers it's but it's it's very
funky schedule for the whole tearless
but I'm gonna run out of time and thomas
tom account is still 15 minutes rent
session hmm we can talk after by the way
it's still expensive don't get me wrong
asni if i have a fixed key I can do for
encryptions ECB because it's pipelined
at 74 cycles so yeah it's still it's
still much much more expensive than
using fixed kaes now in fact you want to
look at times this is the graph that i
get if i do the naive or again naive
here is pipelining it's it is pipelining
the encryptions it's not fully naive but
it's not with our optimized key schedule
you see that we do actually have a very
very big improvement by pipelining the
key schedule together with the
encryption and doing this special
handmade key schedule and not using the
the keygen assist instruction doesn't
your father worked at until
doesn't your tendon tell as well yeah so
one could be just using the next version
to just make an ATP schedule yeah well
tell tell Intel that the you mean the
cost of building a very good pipeline
into the chip is very expensive so
examples of the one option or just don't
think things work that easily okay so
this is this is mike slide and and if
you just came out at the top from from
from mike's talked and basically
understanding it okay if i want to use a
es in the standard ways an encryption
algorithm then i'm going to cost me like
about six seconds instead of three
hundred microseconds and but then you
might say oh okay that's not really fair
maybe it's two seconds instead of three
hundred microseconds and the answer is
no if you want to do if you want to use
a yes as a regular encryption scheme is
a regular pseudo-random function the
cost is not two or six seconds to three
hundred microseconds it's a difference
in three hundred and seven hundred
microseconds that's the difference now
is that greater greater or is that
almost the same it depends it's double
the cost double is a lot but it's also
four hundred microseconds okay four
hundred microseconds is not a lot so
what is so first of all what is the
point of garbage yes as opposed to any
other circuit on that it's just an
example circuit that we use that's what
I thought then what is different between
the yellow and the grade the these are
different ways of doing the double
encryption inside each gate so doesn't
matter that I'm computing the line maybe
isn't too many too much use of AES this
is a circle with 7,000 and gates okay so
I want to gobble us up with 7,000 and
gates when I encrypt each gate I have to
do double encryptions if I use a
standard double encryption using AES as
a pseudo-random function it's going to
cost me six seconds if I do this fixed
kaes it's going to cost me three hundred
microseconds the answer is no it's going
to cost you to use a yes as an
encryption scheme as a pseudo-random
function is going to cost you seven
hundred millisecond seven hundred
microseconds it's gonna it's not going
to be a very big difference it's more
expensive on massive circuits it'll
definitely make a big difference on this
sort of circuit let's see what actually
happens when you run it in an actual
protocol but even just garbling it's not
such a big difference this is the
difference between you the random Oracle
based poop an approved an ideal Sipho
and pseudo random function yes I was
going to give me more time with all
these questions have a circuit with
varrick source I didn't talk back so yet
don't omit the double encryption so far
I haven't talked it about freaks or
Easter Pena this depends on how many
this depends this is really talking
about the cost of garbling gates
irrespective yet over and it hasn't out
have any abroad in a quick issue of
freak soybean which it's ideal cypher
this gets rid of a deal size so in this
lightly look we are only looking at the
encrypting one row right so it looks at
20 now this cigarette it's a double but
in fact you're doing four rows of the
time so the pier and doing this is doing
the entire this is doing seven thousand
nine gates no no but the thing you have
on the left right this is just the
encryption of a one row but if you look
at the whole gate then the purity in the
first case if your app it's using class
right because if i use twice here I'll
see is twice so is that we are used
twice yes I'm doing eight encryptions
and forkie schedules they're doing for
encryptions so I'm doing much much much
more work but it's not that much more
expensive
let's continue because i have also want
to get to the other part of the talk
which is getting rid of freaks or or
freaks or again cross the circularity it
costs us related key and do we actually
have to pay that costs and what what
happens if we want to rely solely on a
PRF assumption so we have these input
keys to our Sergei ki 0 K 1 K j0k j1 and
these are random keys there is no fixed
relation there's no Delta there's no
there's this is just random keys and I
want to get out put keys k0l k 0 1 which
are also just random keys so I wanted to
really sort of standard garbling type
things and this is in exact because I'm
leaving out all this permutation bits
that Mike talked about so the first step
that I want to do is I want to translate
I want to translate these keys to be
specific for the gate why I can go to
many gates and then we have things
repeating so we don't like that so what
I do is I simply apply the pseudo-random
function to the gate identity and I get
tilde key so I just get a version of the
key which is Pacific for this gate it's
not expensive because AES doesn't cost
anything Lynette the next step is I want
to set the offset of the wire I want to
do like a freaks or type thing but it's
specifically for this gate so it's not
going to require any assumption other
than a PRF assumption so I'm just going
to set Delta L to be the XOR of these 2
tilde values and then I'm going to now
translate also the input the wires the
input keys on the other wire on the j
wire and I want to make these also have
an offset of Delta L so how do I do that
well the 01 I'll just just apply AES
again or PI the surrender function again
and I'll computed on the art this should
be a 0 here on the gate identity and the
one value I will simply are XOR with the
Delta so I'll just mask I'll mask the so
I just compute the one value to be the 0
X or with the Delta so now I have that
the I values and the J values have these
fixed the same Delta I can use the
freaks or type technique but it's
specific to this gate so there's no
related key there's no circularity
there's no this is just a pseudo-random
function
Delta L Delta L via typos and now I've
constructed these and I can just use
freaks or and you can define the L
output wires to be the X or the
appropriate X oars and and everything is
fine the only problem is how do i
compute the gate so if I have ki 0 & ki
one in either of these two I can easily
compute the tilde values because just
applying pseudo-random function if I
have k j 0 another type okay Jerry's er
can also just compute the tilde because
that is also just a pseudo-random
function but if I have KJ one I can't
compute KJ 1 tilde because I have I
don't know Delta so i'll give you one
ciphertext i'll simply a mask the KJ one
tilt tilt tilt ax with the pseudo-random
function applied on the KJ one key and
so I lead one ciphertext that's all
that's needed and I can evaluate by
computing either the X or here or this
XOR and i can tell you which way to do
it using a permutation bit and i'll have
to pay 1x1 ciphertext for an xor gate
without losing anything in terms of the
assumption this is a pure PRF assumption
there's no nothing more than a es su
random function I don't need any related
key any correlation robust any
circularity nothing ideal nothing fancy
no multilinear maps even and and we
prove that this that this is insecure
and what we get is that the cost of
garbling an xor gate is a single
ciphertext we need four key schedules
and for encryptions for guarding the
gate we need to key schedules and two
encryptions for a value in the gate but
again these are actually very very cheap
in today's world it's cheaper to do AES
than to read from memory can you explain
again why you don't need the circularity
your relay because it's something which
is related to delta which is only in
this gate afterwards it's it's it's new
in every single gate it's different it's
only in the output no it's not because I
translate my input labels using AES
that's where i apply AES and then I a
chest X or I don't play I don't apply
AES after i computed the Delta it's only
beforehand
okay assuming a period yeah yeah
Louisville circuits and cure Jesus yeah
you shouldn't I mean it's a it's yeah I
don't know it's possible you could do
such a thing but I notice I don't even
need to be a PRP it's just a PRF it's
pretty weak I'm I'm happy with that but
you're right you could even possibly try
to reduce it further forward to row
reduction which mike mentioned using
polynomial interpolation i won't go into
the details but once we don't have
freaks or any more than we definitely
want to use this photo to row reduction
but it turns out that apart from the
fact that it's not for free because
interpolation does cost it's also quite
complicated to implement and so as been
eventually there's actually nothing
special that polynomial relation is just
linear relations and we have a new photo
to row reduction technique which just
requires computing 2x source and doesn't
need anything else so we can do this are
very very efficiently and more even more
importantly very very simply it's really
really simple just computing 2x source
that's also in the paper and we also
show that you can compute not gates for
free when you have freaks or not so
automatically for you just take one wire
which has one always and use it as an
XOR gate it turns out that knot is
really really easy to do in any case and
so this is also for free ok just 2x
source ok so what happens in the end
let's have a look at what what the
actual results are so we ran sem you
honestly out to see the cost in the
protocol why Semyon is now number
licious because this is actually bad for
us malicious would be much better for us
because it's so much other noise going
on then i won't make any direct think
the difference in the cost and garbling
and communication won't make a big
difference but it's semi honest that's
where it will be most significant so
this is the worst case for us and we ran
it on amazon between Virginia and
Virginia like in the same zone and also
Virginia Island where there's more
costly communication and read on three
circuits a
yes sha-256 and min cut so seven
thousand twenty five thousand a million
and gates respectively 25,000 for two
thousand and two and a half million sore
gates respectively okay and this is the
results that we got look at the yellow
lines because these are the best so to
speak this is the ideal cypher
assumption okay it costs 16 milliseconds
to running out semi on earth if you're
happy to go if you just want to get rid
of the ideal cypher assumption okay
you're happy to leave use freaks or but
you don't want ideal Sipho it costs 16
milliseconds and if you don't want to
use anything but a PRF it costs 16
milliseconds why because even when you
just in Virginia the communication is
the is the bottleneck on a circuit of
this size nothing else really matters
even when once you optimize of course
over here if you're going far away then
the communication is much more the
bottleneck but now it costs more so when
you're sending more with that freak so
is sending more so goes up from 195 to
200 milliseconds you're paying five
milliseconds to use only a pseudo-random
function assumption if you go to a
really big circle which is two and a
half million sore gates then yeah this
is going to cost you double the cost so
the answer is is not that yes you can
always throw away are these more
circular already key assumptions but it
is there is a trade-off and it depends
what you're computing when you go for
really big circuits which have lots of
swords like this two and a half times
the amount of X source then and then
yeah this is going to be significant but
but when you get rid of the the ideal
cipher assumption and just using freaks
/ without using fixed k h6 key so yeah
its twenty percent it's not it's not
necessarily massively significant this
is the graph that we get and just to
compare that's the graph that we thought
that we had right so it's actually a
very very different graph maybe four min
cut its it looks more it looks closer
but it's not because it finishes here it
doesn't finish down here and when you
talk about smaller circles which are not
small the shower 256 circuit is not a
small circuit it's nowhere near the
graph that we thought that we had okay
so it's a very very different trade off
to what we thought
and the penalty for lying on a SS around
function is much lower than we thought
for larger circuits with many many
circuits it's more significant of course
but it's less significant again when you
go far away so so you know for the
shower 256 when you go to between
Virginia and island the difference is
between 199 and 230 milliseconds for the
entire protocol so it's really not very
significant so for fixed pas the gain is
even smaller when using the aes circuit
which is only 7,000 gates and gates then
it's it's it comes out at zero and and
we see that it's it's really you're not
gaining nearly as much as you thought
that you're getting good question i
don't know i don't i don't know i think
that what I definitely want to say from
this work is that studying garbled
circuits not just to make it faster
under whatever assumption you can come
up with but also to make it faster under
standard assumptions is a direction
which is worth pursuing I don't think
that I don't hope this is not the best
possible so yeah maybe we can do even
better than that and then improve the
trade-off even further because the
circuits so big and the noise on the
network because it's so far away was so
significant the results were meaningless
the variance was so big because I was so
far away it didn't mean anything but
that is an argument why also doesn't
really make much of a difference which
way which way you gobble it just was a
meeting it was just was meaningless the
average meant nothing because the
variance was so great yeah possibly yeah
ok so the lib if you go to malicious
security protocol that is secured in
prison for malicious adversary's there
will be even less significant and so
once again the argument that we should
always take the how you measure
efficiency is important it's not how
much across the gobble the circuit it's
how much it costs to run the protocol
let's standard assumptions and I always
argued
is when when the gain is significant
than yes you need to use a random Oracle
because there's no choice that's you
know it's the difference is so great but
when the difference is mine are it's not
clear that we really should be doing
this and knowing them right mind would
use fixed key AES in SSL why not it's
saving time and I have to the key
schedule and the answer is because I'm
not gaining that much I'm just doing one
key schedule so why would I use
something which is less standard and
here too if I'm competing a circuit of
the size seven thousand gates or so that
the difference is not significantly
really shouldn't be doing it there's no
reason to do it said you're surfing with
the questions that in finish and while
we are sitting the next talk given us so
this is just a summer that sum up that
we need for the study and the argue end
I guess the conceptual argument will
claim is don't just run as fast as
possible like a more efficient also look
at the assumptions we're using and try
and make it efficient under standard
assumptions as well it's not just
feasibility proofs versus as efficient
as possible there's also trade off
between assumption and efficiency okay
thank you very much
and while promoting stepping trophy
animal questions
yeah so question is a like running this
on Amazon a couple two questions they're
related one for running this on Amazon
about cost in dollars so we pay per and
pay for time protocol is communicating
but not actually you running cycles you
pay for that or you pay the same yeah I
don't know if it yet you paid the same
pay for the amount of time you need to
process running the instance is running
second question is how so these
optimizations that you were mentioning
are specific to the particular chip are
they portable to you know I don't know
so a ESN I is becoming more and more and
more popular modern cell phones have
them on them and but if you want if you
don't have that then you have to redress
a lot of stuff which is being done it
completely changes the playing field for
sure you may want to go back to using
chard and it's it's but it's something
which is becoming less and less the case
let's get there getting everywhere then
let's Thank You Megan